[Music]
it's our tradition to have these
seasonal preview videos where we count
down the top 10 anime that people
anticipate in an upcoming season
but usually around half of those entries
are filled with sequels of popular anime
for obvious reasons
hence we're going to change things up a
little bit i know i already had
something pretty similar to this before
but we'll have a second go at counting
down the top anime to look out for this
fall 2020
but this time i'll be intentionally
excluding sequels and focusing only
on new anime so with those sequels out
of the way which shows will make it to
the list
stay tuned to find out
at number 10 we begin with i'm standing
on one million lives and right off the
bat we get an
issac this time it's the trio of friends
yusuke
kusuwe and eu who get transported into
another world full of mythological
creatures
now the thing is the two girls get some
cool character class assignments
becoming a warrior and a magician while
yusuke is left with
being a farmer what a nice fate indeed
i'm pretty sure that a lot of people
would have been quite sick of this harem
like it's a guy set up by now
but having read the manga i think that
i'm standing on one million lives still
has its own charm
for one it's a series where the isekai
setting really does matter and there's
an overflow of details in kerpa into
crafting the world and the characters so
trust me
this isn't your random throwaway season
or isakai it's far from it in fact but
you do need to stick with it for quite
some time it's also illustrated by the
guy that drew trinity seven one of the
series that i really enjoyed so there is
that too
i gotta ask you if you remember hayate
the combat butler
of course you do and here he comes with
his next work this anime is the story of
nasa yuzaki
who falls in love at first sight upon
noticing the cute tsukasa only for it to
lead to his doom
as he fails to detect danger and finds
himself getting hit by a truck
barely alive thanks to the girl nasa
resolves in his dying breath to confess
and that he did
receiving the girl's proposal of
marriage not a bad way to go out now is
it right
at least he got to do something before
he eventually succumbs to his inevitable
death and wakes up in another what what
wait he survives hey and that promise he
made at death's door has not left his
mind either
he resolves to find tsukasa to no avail
before an unexpected visitor comes to
his doorstep one day
the visitor none other than his wife
fun hijinks a lot of laughs and some
legitimately touching moments are
all on the table we won't have to wait
any longer than the first few days of
october for this one
in our eighth spot we have our last
crusade or the rise of a new world
oh boy here we go with the long
contrived titles but this series is
actually one that i'm really
anticipating and no
it's not an isekai title despite it
looking very much like one war has raged
for years between the empire and nebulas
residents of the two realms contrasted
by their focus on technology and magic
have no love lost between them that is
until 16 year old iska gets awarded the
empire's highest title
and gets his chance encounter with
nebulous princess falling in love with
each other for differing reasons
the two try to change the world in their
own separate ways now this series gives
off some serious romeo and juliet vibes
in terms of premise but i've always been
a sucker for these technology versus
magic settings
it helps that the main character designs
also appeal to me a lot too so i'm
really excited to see how the story will
develop from this point out
[Music]
familiar title that's to be expected for
yet another victim of the multiple
delays but it finally looks like all
systems go for akudama drive this time
round this anime original brings us to a
japan that's been divided thanks to a
war between
kanto and gansai following the war it
would also seem that things would become
more peaceful but it's not all sunshine
in gansai which has become dependent on
kanto
danger lanes in every corner of the
treacherous alleys and the government
has started losing control to the
criminals
known as akudama akodama drive for me
gives off some western movie vibes with
its dark and noir-like atmosphere its
tagline of
everyone is a villain also helps
solidify that impression for me i
personally don't have the highest
opinion of studio period but given that
it's from the creator of danganronpa and
what we've seen in the pvs
i do believe that we're getting the
awesome dark show of the season with
akudama drive
[Music]
sixth on the list is moriarty the
patriot presumably following the
momentum from millionaire detective we
get another mystery detective series
this october starring a more familiar
face
those fans of classic literature would
be no strangers to the name
william james moriarty yes we indeed
have an anime about the sherlock holmes
villain on our hands here now in a
pretty nifty spin on the world of
sherlock holmes moriarty the patriot
stars the villain and tells us the story
from his perspective
we get to see moriarty's backstory and
how he copes with growing up in the
cutthroat world of the european 19th
century
as a member of the nobility beyond the
calm demeanor of a gentle private
consultant
lies one of the most diabolical
masterminds hell bent on shaking the
very foundations of the world
so is he really so bad after all with
the popularity of villainous stories in
anime recently
it didn't surprise me for one of
literature's most beloved villains to
get his spotlight in an anime the blend
between anime and classic
literature has generally been a mixed
bag but with a charismatic villain like
moriarty i think that we're gonna have a
lot to like
about this anime
[Music]
coming in at number five we have the day
i became a god now at this point in time
you probably know why this one makes the
list right social media hype alone makes
the title one of the most anticipated
new anime coming this season
and with someone like jun maeda on board
then why wouldn't it be
june maeda's next foray into the
supernatural drama genre
tells of yuta narugami spending the end
of his summer vacation
preparing for his life ahead university
entrance exams and all of that
however things get a bit muddled when he
encounters a girl named hina
who claims to be the god of omniscience
being able to predict the future is cool
and all
but it's no laughing matter when the
girl proclaims that the end of the world
is in 30 days
overall this show looks amazing i think
that i have a vague idea on how things
will develop from here on out now if you
missed out on the magic of angel beats
and clan and when they were airing make
sure to put this thing on your watch
list
and given the track record that we have
i'm sure that it will be one roller
coaster of emotions once everything's
said and done
[Music]
the much beloved and hit webtoons about
to get its anime adaptation
and the hype is just insane i long
considered nobody's one of the titles
that helped put korean webtoons on the
map
and it's just so fitting that we'll
finally get to see it in an anime
adaptation
for those who don't know novelis tells
the story of rai a powerful noble who's
just awakened from his 800-year slumber
waking up to a world completely
different from the one he left behind
he gets to the first order of business
finding his most loyal servant
frankenstein dealing with the unresolved
conflicts from the past
ryan takes the fight with his power as a
noble in order to protect society so how
about a korean series taking the
overpowered protagonist
angle for a change make no mistake
novelis looks pretty good
and i can't wait to see if the series
really lives up to the hype of the
webtoon
well if it isn't one of the most beloved
visual novels out there getting a long
awaited remake in 2020 can this year get
any wilder a lot of you anticipating
this series probably know what it's all
about but for those who don't
higurashi is basically the story of our
protagonist
keiji maibara and is moved to the
peaceful village of hinamizawa there he
meets a couple of girls and befriends
them
hoping to start a relaxed and happy life
with everyone however things are a bit
amiss
as he gets tangled up with a long
storyline involving murder in the
village's annual festival
to make things worse though it seems
that his friends aren't what they seem
to be the base visual novel is one of
the masterpieces in the horror genre
back in its day can this 2020 version
recapture the magic and the terror
brought about by one of the legacy
visual novels during the peak of the vn
industry we're gonna have to wait to
find out
next we take a look at burn the witch
daite gubo
is at it again and this time we have
ourselves an action fantasy series said
in the same universe as bleach
now if you're one of the many who grew
up watching that timeless classic then
you're in
for a treat here set in london burn the
witch puts us in a world that has quite
the nostalgic feel to it however in
place of hollows
it's dragons that plague people in
london being responsible for over 70
of human casualties luckily special
people with magical powers known as
wizards or witches stand in their way
inhabiting reverse london these people
can see and hunt down dragons
which duo noel and ninny are protection
agents for wingbind
an organization that fights dragons and
deals with managing
outbreaks of those invisible monsters
however things get complicated when
balgo
a human acquaintance of noels gets
caught up in a dragon attack
burn the witch comes out this fall
what else to top our list of anticipated
new anime than the newest prospect in
the world of shonen anime yuji itadori
despite all of his athletic gifts
decides to join his schools a cult club
that's in desperate need of members as
fate would have it though the club opens
the proverbial pandora's box through a
cursed
object leading itadori to his encounter
with sorcerer megumi fushiguru finding
themselves pushed to a corner against
the spirit residing in that cursed
object hitadori seals it by swallowing
the object becoming host
to the king of curses now housing the
dark power within him itadori finds
himself dragged into the world of curses
and sorcerers where one wrong move
could be the end of him i think that i'm
gonna like this and seeing a lot of
people are eagerly awaiting this anime
it seems to be shaping up to be the
blockbuster of this season a lot of fans
can't wait and
i'm one of them too whether this will
become a big hit or not comes down to
the execution now
no sequels and it looks like fall 2020
can be one season to remember whether it
ends up being as big as summer is still
up in the air but i'm liking its chances
way to recover closing out the year
anime industry i'll leave you at this
for now but i really look forward to
seeing you again for the next video
don't forget to like share and subscribe
if you haven't already and hit that
notification bell so you never miss any
uploads
i'll see you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]
you